et pour la 27e fois c'est aujourd'hui la
fête de la musique dans les villages et
dans les villes on va jouer chanter et
danser avant de retrouver christophe
mail l'une des révélations de l'année
les premières images de ce rendez vous
et les préparatifs avec christophe
airaud et mathieu nivet mollo ce qui
génère de james bond et une cour du
palais de l'elysée la 27e fête de la
musique commence les parisiens rentrent
chez le président et le musicien en
uniforme fait toujours son effet sont
ces dames avec leurs costumes
magnifiques on n'a pas l'habitude de
voir de près
on ne traite pas des venues justice
en milieu d'après-midi man foule
présidentielle c'était la première fois
que la fête de la musique assez par
l'elysée
en vingt-sept orp la fête a changé c'est
devenu un concert géant la preuve en ce
premier soir d'été plus de dix mille
spectacles auront lieu à travers la
france
je veux y avait un petit côté à vous
preniez tout si vous tombez sous la main
je vais gagner faire un peu de bruit
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je pense que
on va écouter des talents et puis on a
envie aussi de faire écouter son talent
sa propre station
le ciel est gris les gens aigris je suis
prêt si je suis saisi
il n'aime plus paris alors il a fumé
vers le château de vincennes
le ciel n'est pas gris et à l'issue des
dernières répétitions
thomas dutronc est content je suis si
bien d'un temps les
on a de la chance aujourd'hui pour une
fois c'est depuis le début de l'année
c'est la première fois qu'on fait un
festival en plein air tout ça où il fait
vraiment beau on a eu des on a eu du
tout on a eu des tempêtes de neige en
avril à rennes en a eu des toutes sortes
de galère sous la pluie et tout çà et là
pour une fois ça y est on est dehors et
ça y est c'est l'été donc c'est
vachement bien
est ce que la musique c'est l'été cet
après midi il y avait deux chamoniard je
ne craignais pas la galère sous la neige
il s'appelle l'épiça lochon 4800 tu veux
être le concert plus haut de france et
pas voisins pour se plaindre du bruit
alors et pour la 27e fois c'est
aujourd'hui la fête de la musique dans
les villages et dans les villes on va
jouer chanter et danser avant de
retrouver christophe mais l'une des
révélations de l'année les premières
images de ce rendez vous et les
préparatifs avec christophe airaud et
mathieu ni wendel au ski la mère de
james bond et une cour du palais de
l'elysée la 27e fête de la musique
commence les parisiens rentrent rochelle
président et le musicien en uniforme
fait toujours son effet sans ces dames
avec leurs costumes magnifiques on n'a
pas l'habitude de voir de près
mon trackpad est venu jusqu'ici
milieu d'après-midi man foule
présidentielle c'était la première fois
que la fête de la musique assez par
l'elysée en 24 heures la fête a changé
c'est devenu un concert géant la preuve
en ce premier soir d'été plus de dix
mille spectacles auront lieu à travers
la france
je veux y avait un petit côté à vous
preniez tout ce qui me tombait sous la
main je vais vous alliez faire un peu de
bruit c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui je pense
que on va écouter des talents et puis on
a envie aussi de faire une côte est son
talent sa propre passion je serai la
gueule les gens aigris
je suis prêt si je suis saisi il n'aime
plus paris alors il a fugué vers le
château de vincennes
le ciel n'est pas gris et à l'issue des
dernières répétitions
thomas dutronc très content je sais si
bien dans l'est
on a de la chance aujourd'hui pour une
fois c'est depuis le début de l'année
c'est la première fois qu'on fait un
festival en plein air tout ça où il fait
vraiment beau tu vois on a eu des on a
eu tout on a eu des tempêtes de neige en
avril à rennes on a eu des équipes
sortent de galère sous la pluie et tout
çà et là pour une fois ça y est on est
dehors et ça y est c'est l'été donc
c'est vachement bien parce que la
musique c'est l'été cet après midi il y
avait deux chamoniard qui ne craignait
pas la galère sous la neige il s'appelle
l'épiça lochon 4810 mètres
le concert plus haut de france et pas
voisins pour se plaindre du bruit